it's been nice to be able to have my
classes here at home and then Derek
walks to school so we can have them at
the same time and that's something
that's typical around here is like the
teachers don't charge any extra to come
to your house so yeah it's really nice
yeah I'd say the most surprising thing
since we've been back has been the rain
we definitely didn't expect it to be
this rainy this late in the season I do
miss not being able to go to school with
Derek but I know that it's better for me
to study at home right now because it's
easier for Israel Israel can be a little
distracting whenever I'm trying to
concentrate
I'm so grateful for Jessica because
she's a mom to just two boys and so it's
nice having somebody that you can relate
to and that when Israel is fussing or
something then she'll just incorporate
that into my lesson
vamos a estudiar espanol cc1 with is the
edge paniolo red hear the rooster all
right it feels really good to me back in
the swing of things with language school
if you look said use that's the one yeah
but it stays like these that I really
missed my sisters
you